[Music]
where
therefore on the adaptation of the processes and
the reminder to translate this morning
to the complete
[Music]
very small part therefore especially what
they attack alive and in
particular
the canuts either
the cliff that it is much larger
of  see the question of
how we are going to deal with all of his
nerves of his cards
so there an approach
that is proposed we will say to
in fact capture all these guys and how we
will see it analysis and
adaptation of the processes the same  session
it's second session you
local approach that we propose in the end
sector a
magician approach [Music] you will seem each
time to define the perimeter of the
pine forest activities to properly approach the
entrances if the role of
each one so there we are  soda base on
an iso 40.2 euro standard said that they were
suspending a method of
formalizing the different points of view
with which we will look at this system
their occurrence the system is
the environment  nt of confidence and to
see it how we go
from the sifi this environment of confidence
course different points of view that this
time the view and at points of financial details
users
all scarponi
so compared to
your dear to the functional we have already
seen several times  to
the army because I play less
to explain very quickly it is the
answer part to succeed the moment if
we spoke about wolf the social point of view
in val d'
oise all the activities necessary
to carry out
[Music]
the development of an integrating system,
well knowing that when I say
development it is indeed the
development phases but it is also the
maintenance in flight condition
the operation and the maintenance in
operational conditions of this system must
cover all of its activities
with the people who go a
Julian field on its activities
there to understand that its cell and a
grouping the activity and on this role
my assets can be seen here refer  ie the
much lower blue morning
there will be a lot of changes between its
different activities and each of these
two fields I'm going to be really uncertain
cycle 2 and it's through these changes
of state we'll say about these data that we
'll be able to  nidal
capture the fact that
and1
good bhagwan from a point of view
therefore the points of view in a which are
considered so far the breakdown has
not clean them associating I know
how much time but overall he has
everything that is analysis
risk during the v gard
system development cycle whether in
engineering basically I made a
big mistake what is
the impact we are going to say on the
confidence I have  in my system at the operating system level
we talked about the
mosquito on the camera his voice as an
impact on the confidence that i will
do
how i will gain by the use of
for example ningbo libraries
and how i will gain confidence
through there in interaction I go  there I can
have or not with
my system which integrates links is
therefore the objective with describing in
fact all of these points more is
and capitalizing a little simple agent than
what we have also seen the different
presentations it  is that necessarily to be
obliged to respect for a few steps from the
museum at the risk of luxury or alliances
it is necessary we always have emotions to
teach you precisely which were the
skeptics we have in fact behind and who
will finally apply to  all
the problems
so far to consider all the same a
lot of engineering disciplines are
necessary for the development of the system
of the big
dates there
in fact
the localities of course on the
specificities of lian li is not it
cover all the processes
just looked at those that are
impacted by the pollution of there is of
course in wallachia all that on a case-by-
case theoretical basis invites the states and of
course these are
so there we are right in the middle of it
the organization in the reflections on
how to capture one's knowledge we
are in the process of evaluating different tools
to capitalize on all that eh but
the idea is that it serves behind bram
the whole thing
is therefore but anyway here it is specified for
some time to them  sense of service
culture of selling in a corner by
parliament to sink
all of his hands in the final
here is for the fight part well
instances is there and I pass the hand
borloo and eric
well I'm happy to moult you
so I'm going to go to him  by experience
went the
time nevertheless we wrote at 406
offset both because it is a
logical continuation the first case of a famous husband
but still it is what one can
guess table as long as qualified in  the
domain to the principles of the ben ali system
for the match by the legacy as a bonus
a comparable increase are
determined and also to be able to
identify what are the
danger gothics of 2.04 that it of the integration
of ai in  the rgv system
destined for billions in the system
must
control its executioners types of risks
knowing that the metals of the sky like
Germans have returned well tourist
the risk of cancer I showed in
the adjustment it will take
also proposes the construction of the  'human
in calm at a
system at the
starting level of the system is elected mayor
outside the system with which by
interaction in the 30
the second time languages and then in fact
hat are the various elements of th
permit to ensure tensi
n  cigana to have in our system so
also development we will check proof of concept
testing
with can normally
assured the system hero colette
he would try federal puts a coin
power have done the vacuum she
aware i can relate  to this
proof that I defined in relation to
trust here is congratulations to him
we are in phase and develops
development has  We will define the
confines of a level of confidence in the
system developed then you my
power is given the weight of confidence
hop during the operation of sector 9 which
will be deployed since the system being
a system integrating yet there is
this rare
I have him  launched in any weather small
change in the norbourg funds
to be
we go back rationed respect and it is
therefore to be able to guarantee the confidence
that we have the tables of the world
it will not be able to ensure that trusting
would be this concrete act at the level of
the operation of the formation of the system
and at this
second klein slammed
military branches of other projects phase of
design and snowboarding we will
take into account in fact the idea
that we start from zero therefore to be able
in fact reusing what the
good man has learned at the level of the definition of
the development of gnac systems in order
to be able to reintegrate, for example,
the use of components that are
already certified sells results that are
t enough of
course my talents that we have
identified fifteen men
of
profitability it is the specification the
formalization of the aude association
and the way everywhere I am not trained
and the
Morisco bodybuilding is not one that apparently
will celebrate admiration that they say is
expected today from the financing of the
different activities also from the games where
it is necessary to take everything a step to be able to
hire again in
the system
in fact
campaign for the girls we do not know
of course the known barrels that  they have
already learned that
they are accustomed to the 800 to a
billion taboo take into account the
considerations
and from this 7th google a
new risk of hiring but are poorly
suited the generic rates
would stop recognize it don't believe me
of  intention
at the level of the specification of the
operational domain we are going in the direction of
refugees brought three priests which will
happen in mainly three concept
the definitioni  we make it a taxonomy the
pressure of a data tax that they
are close to where do they come from so i
critical systems
the relationship anthology devotion this action
we will support it to cede this
asteroid
to see the relationships  between france
and the hands and then the strata iran
wines of the operational domain which
relates to a system challenge themselves to marie
of order at home and
morality the rational program which is exploitable
in any case on the part of the party located
at the level  from the derision of it
management which you will rely on a
definition of the weak anthology to be
able to define in a video of
limits of the role over time metals
for them to be published
you can create the
critical situations that the  'we will be able to
have that the system can be counted
at the level of its deposit rate are
still operational then in bets on
the definition of scenario subjects
since it must be understood that the audience has
a simple of  together the scenario of a
canopy system and that was
scenario you will also have
future situations is criticized as
acquired and recalled that this
enchantment the piece so they will be
at the animus when finally
nominal behavior of the system it will take  into
account the measures of riffs the measures
of education which are appropriate and which
one learns gel of the type of situation
to be able to ensure that one is in a
box in a camp on in order
to bring while  we focus on the
theme of treated water, that is to say the
problems of the operational domain of the
system we share a little outside
the aude and the paramount po would have
had to be defined which are the rules
which allow us to be able to  I had seen
the border of our
water to help our rational system and
they are the rules for not having
to cross in fact this agency
we have the level of the cold water
navigation which will be rather beautiful
adventure of the tâc  hes next
interrupt
being that one has to see a
few example per game
so gonna throw on the
unfolded in fact of this
approach actually on a
working with
i know my level of this cold
they worked on an interview
achieving good  ideas
you dreamed of being hungry we
had 17 caramelization but which does
not correspond exactly to the definition
of oblivion which I think that even before
talking about fashion was quite high level it
will finally be necessary to define that in this
steep ascent losing and everything  Suddenly
my fiancé ja's estate then
left in charge for the decade
good idea for a system to get there by
viewing
these three sectors wendel seoul
in fury rina müller makes it a
small and all categories to the elements
and to relate bleeding
handle of the priestly ordination
do it on the framework of the structure and
on the four
the negation of the human in fact
draft trial the surety l  e bmi is
homogeneous
I think that in general to
see there only the concretization of what you
propose on opinion on the range some
examples of the club
c then it was very complicated but
objective to see the film where we are going we
work before  the work is
because it's been two years frankly that
we are blamed for we see rather the
theory the probable
modification
[Music] to
meet and the side a golden skin
that's what speaks in fact that on
the other approach a  nice 10th place which
was based on the exploitation of data
much less hopefully some
time it's a bit the system is brought
to meet in fact and dvd in my
soul in terms of growth and the
close power in fact  if you
already had me feel completely from
the audience so it was almost what we
do so I think you will have and
[Music]
the impatience you want we use the term
at the dd which comes out a bit of m mandeville and
during the period  rear drum and the
whole system  me fifty the name neyret he
is supposed to operate in a field which
is not just any plane without
losing certain contexts really it is
not true we do not have the
operational concepts these are things that
we simply know  the need to
formalize so rigorously is that
it did not appear because
today this definition
determines the data that will
determine the behavior of the system in the
end here is the tree again the dd
don't know that new on the other hand
what is beautiful is the effort that we
make to formalize it to
represent it and then we will discover by
invitation mythology to do
things simply when we say the
plane a little crazy I can only take
it off if  the winds are such speeds
power we spoke in front of that does
not run talks to them about speed and sees the
speed and then we related the
baraka speed here is the ontology
is to stage immense and the
concepts that  I  he's stupid in relation to his
steps here it's not us who allows him
it's complicated afterwards to achieve and
the basically a way enough come on we
talk to each other I don't know it's information that
are really good at the service had
just slipped kouchner as a default
something that deviated from
normality
the whole default on the
tax part in fact they lead to
see that
launching strong opposition
on their card it is an opportunity
at the same time at the level of l  delicate water
question of
which crisis the priority or a little dirty
by this brilliant news for
example which works very well of course
certain defects we cannot say that
they are not or have not poured
into the evil of partners
from bkc
a priori we have to
save our irons from rtt there are the notions
of rdd from restricted entirety when
we realize that on the side of the men who
are not covered in the remains of
reindeer we have to open and we ask ourselves
questions about the delta  saed  how
would you ask about additional tests
that we need to
certify you to validate the
functioning of something